[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw as the status symbol of
choice
i'm dave ramsey your host christy wright
ramsay personality number one
best-selling author is my co-host today
as we answer your questions about your
life and your money her new book take
back your time the guilt-free guide to
life balance
one week
one week from today i can't believe it
it feels like the pre-sale has flown i'm
so excited
which means a lot of different things
number one all of you that have already
bought the book and there are a bunch of
you thank you very much uh it'll be
shipped next week and you'll have it on
your doorstep uh somewhere around monday
or tuesday of next week something like
that lots of good stuff going on
and of course uh that also means there's
only one week left in all of the special
deals associated with pre-sale yes so if
you've been holding out because you're
thinking oh i'm not going to get it
because it's not going to ship if you
get it now it will ship very soon and
you get the free stuff but if you wait
until
next week when it launches you're going
to miss out on the e-book the audio book
the ticket to the live event on thursday
the access to the private facebook group
with me and all that good stuff so yeah
if you're thinking about getting it go
ahead even if it's for christmas go
ahead and get it now because you get the
freebies it just makes sense yeah you
get about a hundred dollars worth of
stuff a little less than a hundred
dollars worth of stuff extra when you
buy the 20 book and you buy it this week
rather than next week if you wait
this week at next week at this time
you will pay 20 and you will get a 20
buck yeah and that's what you'll get so
um this is the deal it is uh the
guilt-free guide to life balance is
called take back your time it's all
about productivity it's all about uh
doing not not just being productive but
being productive in a way that allows
your life to be sustainable yeah it does
it really redefines this whole word it's
it's taking a new angle on it i think
that's important because what i've seen
dave and i've definitely been guilty of
this myself is we think the answer to
our balance problem is that we just need
to do more and so we wake up earlier
stay up later and run harder and faster
in between but we still feel like
something's not right and so i help you
get to the root issue of why you feel
like that in the first place i help you
figure out what your version of balance
looks like in the season and then take
very practical steps to achieve it so i
really feel like it's a very new take on
this um
old conversation and to be honest a a
word that needed redefining you know i
hadn't thought about that but if you're
on a tightrope
trying to balance the harder you try
the the more out of balance you get and
the more people yell at you that you
need to be in balance the harder it is
and have you ever seen a tiger walker
like they're not looking like they're
having fun like every fiber on their
body is tense i don't want to live like
that i i don't want to live like that so
i'm like let's give it a lot of people
kind of in a secret part of their soul
are wishing they fall i mean come on i
mean
we've got all these analogies of
tightrope walking spinning plates and
juggling balls i don't want to live my
life like that that sounds hard risky
and you know what
therein lies the problem we have in our
world today our lives are a circuit
i'm here to help you with your circus
all of this balance stuff happens in the
circus stop it
stop it get out of the tent get away
from the circus get away from the three
rings
and uh let's start doing the right
things at the right time in the right
degree for where you are right now in
this season and that's christy's take on
this stuff it's going to help a bunch
september 13th is the last day to do the
pre-order that means that is the last
day that's the last day to pre-order the
book get 50
plus almost 100 worth of goodies on
thursday night of next week one week
from this thursday she and i will be
doing a live stream event uh to go along
with the book take back your time the
guilt-free guide to life balance and it
is called what take back your time life
who knew so crazy that's a strange name
for us to do having something to do with
this book but yeah there you go so it's
actually christy is doing the event and
they're letting me be on there for a few
minutes so i can act like i'm important
everybody knows better so and it's a
book signing if you come in nashville
it's a book signing you get your book
signed if you want to join us here in
person and you can get a ticket
got a few slots left not many it's
pretty well pretty well booked up it's
not a big crowd we're going to have for
the uh live studio audience that's it
but uh you can do that and come out and
it's going to be a great event that that
event is a paid live stream or free uh
it's free if you if you get your
pre-order copy of the book okay so go
ahead get your copy otherwise you're
gonna have to pay to watch it yeah and
that's at ramseysolutions.com and the
other thing that i want people to know
too which has been kind of fun dave last
week we sent out the ebook to all the
people that have pre-ordered by that
date i believe it was september uh first
and we're already getting reviews so if
you're on the fence go to
ramseysolutions.com you can look at
reviews for the book for our early
readers and see what they think and hear
from real people so um that might answer
some questions if you have any very cool
stuff all right andrew is first up this
hour in detroit michigan andrew welcome
to the ramsey show how can we help
hi dave hi christy congrats on the new
book thank you for taking my call sir
um
so i'm calling uh
it's relatively uh fresh news um but my
mom
has been pretty sick with uh diabetes
these last few
months and has she's on the upswing of
it but
from it her vision has gone so she's
just been declared illegally blind
um
and
you know so she's applied and she's
going to be on disability
making about 1800 dollars a month
which is not a lot um in comparison to
what she was making which was i want to
say closer to 3 000 a month um
but i
i guess just generally um my mom's
pretty steadfast that she wants to uh
keep working um in some capacity and
she's a very independent human being so
i've no doubt she'll find a way to make
that happen in some way but
i guess um
i'm just asking about just general
advice with
limitations of income like that um
obviously the scope of her abilities are
going to be a lot lower than what they
were um how you might work your way uh
through the baby steps um so right now
she
has about 25 000
in debt um i intend personally about
paying about half that because it was
for a student loan of mine um and she
has about
30 000 in the bank um
she's
she doesn't know a lot about you um i
follow you a lot obviously dave um but
yeah how old is he uh
my mom is 57
5'7
yes and you're how old
i'm 24. oh my goodness and what do you
make
uh me i make um 89 000 a year okay
well i'm sorry this is a tough tough
situation for both of you um
uh and she's lucky and blessed to have
you there to walk with her through this
so
uh the uh ssi is what she's gonna be on
will give her the limitations that she
can make in addition to the disability
without putting her disability in
jeopardy
okay
yeah i i believe that's what it is
that's how you say that
it is and they'll give her the
limitations that she can make on the
books legally um some people in those
situations work off the books for cash
um and do whatever they want to do uh
i'm not suggesting that i'm just saying
sometimes that happens
and um so i think then you sit down and
and you work to quickly as you can with
your 89 000 to pay off the portion that
you're going to pay off
and then we're just on a very very very
tight budget uh in her case so it's
going to be a slow
movement
the main thing she's got to do is take
care of herself first and then worry
about this debt and other stuff second
way down the list take care of the food
shelter clothing transportation and
utilities before you do anything else
especially in this situation
[Music]
stop paying your overpriced wireless
provider and switch to puretalk they use
the same network as the larger providers
for much less for just thirty dollars a
month get unlimited talk text and six
gigs of data with no contract the
average family saves over seventy
dollars a month by switching to pure top
just go to puretalk.com and enter the
promo code ramsey to save 50 off your
first month pure talk simply smarter
wireless
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
chrissy wright ramsey personality is my
co-host today as we answer your
questions here on the ramsey show open
phones a triple eight eight two five
five
two two five
muhammad is with us in uh the
netherlands hey how are you
hey dave and chrissy how are you doing
great how can we help
hey i got a real estate question
so
like like you already said i'm in the
netherlands and uh i really like real
estate so i started investing it when i
was
pretty young
and uh but with my work there is an
opportunity come up to come to the
united states
and i was wondering if i should
sell everything and go from there in the
states begin again real estate or should
i keep it maybe and go from long
distance even though i've never even
done something like that and
looks pretty hard so that was my
question basically how long do you think
you'll be in the states
uh for at least this project this would
be a year but uh
i would
i would probably be there for like
forever i mean that's the plan that's
that would be the goal
oh okay so your plan is to move to the
united states permanently
yeah correct yeah okay when do you uh
right now the probability of that uh
right now the probability of one year is
very high
well what's the when will you know more
on a very high level what the
probability of you staying forever is
probably somewhat into that year i'm
guessing
yeah correct yes that's correct yeah
probably after like uh three four months
when uh i can also see about how the
because i'm in the
industrial sector so that would be
if i work with the company and maybe
others as a contractor to see what's the
market like and if i fit into it
well i would hate for you to come down
here for one year
and go back and have sold everything
yep okay yeah so i i probably i'm
probably holding it all for the first
year
and renting it and maybe get some help a
property management firm to help you
rent it with that not being the
long-term play but let's get your
probability locked in that you're not
going back
um okay i mean if you're gonna burn the
ships and you're not going back no
matter what then you can just sell it
all now but i think that your
probability of knowing the market
getting a comfort level
um
uh you know in terms of plugging into
your career that kind of stuff if it
takes you a year to do that in this
first year of your contract
um
feels kind of wise to hold off for one
year and then sell everything what do
you
think yeah that makes sense but i i've
already worked for a couple american
companies like 3m and exxon mobile and
stuff but in the netherlands and belgium
so i already have connections with them
and they offered me in advance but you
know i'd rather be sure than possible
that's why i said they gave me a
contract for a year but uh yeah that
makes sense what you're saying so yeah
well muhammad
the idea too just because this is such a
major life change i mean
major that if you can find any way to
ease into it then it's just going to
reduce your stress and it's going to
give you that safety net and peace of
mind because if you
did burn the ships move hair etc but you
did want to go home
you almost might make the wrong decision
or justify staying because you had
nothing to go back to this way you're
going to be able to look at it more
objectively in a year and say okay do i
want to stay am i ready to sell
everything there or do i want to go back
and you've just got more options and
we're just so big on on helping you guys
have options so you can make the best
best decision i love the idea of you
easing into this where you can yeah i
mean if you had taken a new job uh from
you know inside the united states to
inside the united states and you were
moving and you were not coming back
then we sell everything right you know
that would just be so i mean you're
moving from
i don't know california to texas and
you're not coming back um then yeah you
go ahead and sell the stuff you don't
you don't hold long distance landlording
property as a long-term strategy
this is a little different yeah you
don't know if you're going to like it
you're changing countries yeah
and somewhat you're changing cultures
at least some cultural differences and
so you're going to want to find that
niche and get a comfort level before you
liquidate all the hard work you've done
to this point and then when you sell it
on i don't know what your tax
implications are in the netherlands
would be i don't know anything about
that but certainly you would take that
money and you can move it state
stateside in terms of buying some
some you know some investment properties
and other things here
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five our question
today comes from blinds.com
they have a 100 satisfaction guarantee
that means even if you mismeasure or you
pick the wrong color they'll remake your
blinds for free with free samples free
shipping and the new promos they run
every month you'll save even more use
the promo code ramsey to get the best
deal today's question comes from brodie
in alaska i'm an 18 year old
entrepreneur and i'm starting college
this fall i started a residential
painting company a few months ago we
paint exteriors and interiors and the
business has really taken off quickly i
have one full-time employee and our
success has been so great that we're
turning down work my take-home pay is
1800 per week could you give me some
advice on how to grow my business
quickly without burning myself out well
i'll tell you dave the thing that jumps
out to me about this question is the
fact that he's 18 year old 18 years old
about to start college
so to me that changes the answer a
little bit because you're about to
become a student whereas if this was
your full-time gig you're 30 years old
and you just want to grow it okay we
could talk about increasing your prices
we could talk about hiring more staff
and scaling in that way um but but for
brody i mean your a1 is being a student
so it's not that we're going to ignore
the business i know a lot of college
students that have a business in
addition to being a student i just
wouldn't make that your top priority
where you're sacrificing um
attending classes or doing homework
because you're trying to lead a huge
staff team i don't think that that's the
right priority at this at this stage
yeah if the only thing you do is make
ninety thousand dollars a year while
you're going through four years of
college you're gonna be okay brody that
was pretty ambitious right there you
don't have to add ambition on top of
that we're pretty impressed already dude
you're freaking 18 years old you're
making 1800 bucks a week
take home pay yeah yeah so seriously
that's pretty impressive i don't think
we grow this business i i would i would
grow it only enough to maintain it yep
um and and let's get through four years
of school and uh then maybe you go back
and teach business at that college after
you're done oh my gosh
yeah because most of your professors in
the business category have never made
1800 a week and they're running their
own business
so um there you go
wow that's impressive oh somebody asked
questions like that what a kid man what
a kid i love it all right max is in
chattanooga hey max how are you
good for real better than we deserve
what's up
um so i just had a quick question um
right now i currently have a truck
payment that's about 400 a month
and i have about 6
800 left on it
and i have right now about 16 000 left
in my savings
and i
just recently had to move out of where i
was living where i was able to afford
both the truck payment and my rent and
right now i'm living somewhere where i
don't know if i'll be able to afford
both of those and i was just wondering
if i should take the money out of my
savings and just go ahead and pay the
truck off
well why'd you move somewhere you can't
afford
well it's not that i can't afford it it
was it's just that you can't afford it
well um i don't know if i can afford
both the truck payment and
the where i'm living currently
it was kind of a very last minute thing
and i had to move in a couple of months
and um i just this was about the only
place that was available for me to move
into
how old are you
22. okay i'm calling
bs had a couple of months to make a
decision
and you made a decision to rent a place
you can't afford
that's the you were not forced you were
not forced into this you are not a
victim of the real estate market in
chattanooga you're a victim of how lazy
you were when you were looking for a
place to live
yes
well we're on the same page next we're
on the same page hey we love you man i
love you so much y'all on this truck you
said you owe 6000 on the truck yes i'd
pay it off today what do you make of
your sir
um about 24 25 000. okay what do you do
um i work retail right now and i'm going
back to school next semester to finish
out my degree and what
uh business management great good move
very good call
good so here's what we're gonna do i'm
gonna send you a copy of the book the
total money makeover to show you how to
handle money while you're fighting your
way through this i'm proud of you you're
doing good stuff here's the trick man
don't let stuff happen to you
on the money side you happen to it
you have to make things fit your world
you don't cave to the circumstances
around you or you will lose and that's
what puts you in this position
so i've done it too i know exactly how
it feels that's why i can pick on you
[Music]
christie wright ramsey personality is my
co-host today this is the ramsey show
kelly is with us kelly is in warner
robins georgia hi kelly what's up
hi dave hi chrissy how you guys doing
great what's going on can we help
so
i have quite a few financial questions
but i'm going to stick with the one that
i'm with with right now um
i'm one it's a 401k question and i have
seen and watched a couple of free videos
with people who have about the same
questions with using your 401k to pay
off debt and i know that it is not a
good idea i'm completely aware of it
i don't have a lot in my
401k
so in in my opinion i don't feel like
i'm taking that heart of it and i know
it will because i think it takes like 30
now i'm in the lower tax bracket
um
basically what i'm wanting to use it for
is to purchase a vehicle that i don't
know any money on
i currently have a
truck loan that i'm wanting to get rid
of i want to come up from
this truck loan
so
my plan is to sell it
and then
use what what out of my
401k kind of what's left over after i
purchase a vehicle
to
kind of pay off like the other little
bit of debt that i do have i have a
total of
25
500 in debt and the majority of that is
from my truck how much of this is the
truck
it's 19 300 and how much is in your 401k
i only have 13 000. um that's between i
have so kelly essentially what you're
saying is this okay
in order to execute my plan
i want to borrow thirteen thousand
dollars at thirty percent interest
okay
that's what you're saying
now you're not saying it directly but
that is the effect
of your proposal
okay when the smoke clears and that's
why you've heard this call so many times
as you've watched youtube on the same
subject
and um
here's what's happening and i commend
you for trying to figure out a way out
of this because you've recognized the
truck is the problem and it's got to go
and i really think you're very wise in
that regard
um
but but what ends up happening is
um i know you because i am you i see you
in the mirror when i look in it and
we're people that we're rip the band-aid
off people even if it hurts i want to be
done with it
yes
and
and we have a tendency in making our
financial decisions to let that color
our decision
um
and we don't really i i have
i just i did this stuff in my 20s and i
know exactly how what i know the feeling
that you're like i just want to get this
over with
did i is that correct
yes yes because i see
i see it as hurting me more than i am
like because all of my money is going to
these loans and
i'm actually able to pay it i would
rather have it going
towards like saving i would rather put
that
so
since you bought the truck you've had a
wake-up call and you've you know that's
in the rearview mirror no pun intended
and um you know you're looking back
there and you're going ted gummit and i
got to clean this up now and and but
we've but truthfully i want you to find
a
more painful
slower or a slower way to clean this up
that is more painful on the short term
and less painful on the long term here's
a principle for everybody out there
when it comes to money if it feels good
this week
but bad
over the period of a decade
then it's the wrong decision
right and that's what this one is it
falls in that bucket
because it feels good to cash this out
and clean up all these bills and do all
this other stuff so what do you make a
year
um
it's i'm actually basing it off of my
husband's income because i just recently
within six months have started a
cleaning business
so i make um
from the numbers that i pulled up within
last month i've made about eight hundred
dollars a month so i don't make much
maybe seven hundred or seven seven
thousand a year what does he make
about twenty 000 a year she brings in
about a 480 paycheck every week gotcha
now this truck is killing you then how
much is the truck worth
um i kelly blue booked it at
20
oh no
oh what did the lady tell me i just
remember her telling me don't ever go
less than fifteen thousand um
well i i recently did a quote with
carmax and they told me that they would
give me 17 for it so i mean i would only
owe two grand on it and i know
if you sell it if you sell it private
sale it'll bring enough to pay it off
yes that's that's where i'm going with
this kelly because there is a quicker
path to where you want to get and it
doesn't involve
sacrificing but you don't have a car
then
but if you but even if you got something
in cash small like a thousand two
thousand dollar card do you have any
savings kelly
i've got a little bit um not much what's
a little bit um which is crazy how much
is a little bit
two thousand i have two thousand dollars
okay i want you to sell the truck for 19
and buy 2 000 car
okay
and then i want you to work your butt
off without the truck payment and being
on a budget get your cleaning business
going the great news is that you can
actually make a lot of money in the
cleaning business and you need more
accounts
or you need to raise your prices or
something because oh my goodness i'm
surprised that it did it's doing what
it's doing within the six months like
you should have been doing that in month
one we're gonna change that mindset
kelly if you'll stay on the line we'll
have kelly here give you a ticket to our
business boutique conference in october
it's october 14th through the 16th we'll
show you how to raise your prices we'll
show you how to market your business
we'll show you how to get customers and
get more money that's going to help you
pay off that debt we do it every year
every fall thousands of you have how
much you can do this yeah not counting
the truck only about five thousand
dollars right
six thousand yeah i've got i've got a
personal loan at 1200 and then my credit
card is five thousand okay yeah sell the
truck
sell the truck for enough to pay it off
buy a 2 000 car and cut up your credit
card get yourself on a tight budget hang
on kelly will pick up and we're going to
get you signed up for business boutique
in the meantime we're also going to send
you the business boutique book and
between now and october i want you to
double your income and then when you
come to business boutique you can double
it again
because you should be making four or
five six thousand bucks a month in a
cleaning business right now it's a it's
a freaking gold mine
it's the ultimate we just answered a
question about this with the
blinds.com from an 18 year old of of
having a cleaning business
yeah oh i'm sorry
painting sorry i'm telling you this let
me let me give you guys so this this is
this
so when daniel my son who's a senior
vice president here now and he's an old
man with a baby in the whole bed now but
when he was a kid
we were remodeling doing some remodeling
at our house
and i was ready to kill him because they
wouldn't show up yeah
so we're driving down the street he's 14
years old and he goes
uh dad i think i've decided what my
career is i said what he goes i'm gonna
be a contractor
and i'm like why and he said it looks to
me like there's no competition
because all you have to do is show up
when you said you were going to
meet the price you said you were going
to
and do good work and he goes none of
those are rocket science this is a 14
year old the bar is low i'm just saying
you got no competition in the maid
service business
and in the none yeah
and in the remodeling business or
handyman business i talked to a handyman
the other day making 300k a year
you know what is so interesting though
in the way that kelly talked about that
even though it's just i'm surprised
that i'm making 800. i'm surprised
that's what i want to fix the mindset oh
my god people are giving me charity they
paid me eight no no no you're running
they're toilet serving the marketplace
when you start changing your mind about
your business what it does the money you
can make what you're worth you will
start seeing that money but as long as
you
feel pitiful and act pitiful the results
you will get will be pitiful i a lot of
and you've seen this dave a lot of what
i do through business boutique whether
it's at the conference or book or
whatever is changing the mindset because
that's what changes the actions cringe
injecting courage
my specialty
and just makes you believe because it's
funny once you think you're worth
something you you sound stuck up but
you're not stuck up you go it's
confidence you go do it you go work
there's a lot of difference in
confidence and arrogance yes
arrogance says you really aren't worth
it confidences really are
[Music]
other than that it's pretty much the
same attitude this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
christie wright ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at
825-5225
zach is in omaha nebraska hey zach how
are you
well gonna be honest been a little
better um
we got word today that my dad is
probably not gonna leave the hospital
alive
so
trying to figure out how to help my
family through this a little bit more
because there are like i know what you
guys usually recommend but they're not
really plugged into you guys and i'm
trying to figure out how to guide them
through
the
coming weeks oh zach i'm sorry what's
wrong with him
i think it's some kind of blood
poisoning issue i'm not 100 sure every
time my mom gives an update she
writes like a book so i've lost track of
all the
diagnosis going on
how old are you how old is she
i'm 27 my dad is 60.
oh my goodness okay
um
well
here's the thing it's um when you're
facing something that's this emotional
the um
and this devastating
um
the more facts
you have
most people it lowers our anxiety
gathering the facts might temporarily
increase some people's anxiety in the
mix
but the overall family will be better if
they have good solid facts people are
much more afraid of
the unknown than they are of bad news
and that would include the financial
story that's here okay
the unknown is much more scary than even
the known that i've got some struggles
with okay
that makes sense
yeah that's kind of why i call because
like my mom
there's some financial things that we'll
need taken care of right away and stuff
like that but also
like you usually tell people my mom
needs time to just be able to sit there
and cry and she's got my 14 year old
brother living with her
plus i i got a 23 year old brother who's
living there with his wife and two kids
and i know at the very least one of the
things they want to do quickly is
replace the house because they live in a
fallen apartment double white that
even i don't really want my mom living
in anymore because it's
junk at this point yeah okay
all right um so really there's three uh
major
categories or three buckets that we can
address
um
one the first one is do we know the list
of things that they own
and things that they owe
they own
the house we bought cash for like three
grand and we remodeled it ourselves
there's a small construction loan with
my dad's pickup as collateral i don't
know the exact amount my mom won't tell
me
she has a ford expedition i
if i had to guess i'd say at minimum ten
thousand on that
they got a couple credit cards i don't
know if they're current on payments or
if they have some debt on those and uh
does your mom work i think that's about
it
uh yeah she does okay the second bucket
is
to begin to put together a budget of how
she will live
if he doesn't come home
financially
how she gonna eat
keep the lights on
what's gonna be the game plan that with
the monthly budget what's the monthly
budget look like if he doesn't come home
um that's the second
i'm gonna guess roughly three thousand
dollars yeah and then the third maybe
you said she works and earns what
uh
that that's specifically her income my
dad was on disability for the last
little bit i don't know if she's gonna
get any financial
i don't know if he's got life insurance
i don't believe he does i think he lost
it when he lost his job like six years
ago and uh so let me help you with this
all three answers to all three buckets
so far is
i don't know
okay i don't know what they owe she
won't tell me
i don't know what it takes for her to
live and how much she has coming in
towards that
and i don't know if there's any life
insurance
so i go back to my original statement
would you agree with me zach that not
knowing is more scary than knowing
admittedly yeah like that's where i
guess that was kind of the point i was
gonna try to get out with this question
is i've got those are pretty educated
guesses so my answers are somewhere
around the numbers i gave but
i don't know and mom's pretty stubborn
about telling me anything related to
finances as if she's trying to do it on
her but like she seems to feel like she
needs to do it on her own to an extent
and i'm trying to figure out how to let
her know you're not alone and i know
i've screwed up with my finances but i'm
i've learned a lot
and i want to at least help a little bit
yeah
okay why don't you just say that
um
you're not alone
i know this is scary and i know you're a
strong independent woman
would you allow me to be a shoulder you
can lean on for a short period of time
and let's walk through putting together
a plan to where you can operate on your
own
but i'll help you develop the plan
okay and and if she responds
if she responds to that with a stiff arm
there's nothing you can do then
you can't help people who won't accept
the help
even your own mom
your little brother needs to get a job
and move out today
he's a burden he's not a blessing
not the 14 year old the 23 year old with
a wife living in a trailer with his
mother
to be fair he does have a job
why they won't move out i will event i
don't know yeah well i just said what he
needed to do i didn't say i didn't give
a reason why other than it's ridiculous
yeah and so this is not a blessing it's
a curse it's a problem
and and but but again none of these
people
are required by law to take your input
or mine
and so
um you you
it's very difficult to insert yourself
forcibly into an adult
who has legal rights into their
situation without their permission the
one thing i want to throw in there zach
is um these next few weeks and months
are going to be so hard on all of you
all
if you offer to help
once
and she says no you can keep offering it
does not hurt to come back around two
weeks and be like hey i'm here but what
hey i'm here but what i don't want you
to do
is to try to help a where you're not
welcome or be where you have incomplete
information or cooperation yeah
if she says i'm not doing that then you
go okay yeah but but if if she may come
around she may come around a couple
weeks after trying to do it herself and
she wants help but might be too proud to
ask for and if you're there going hey
i'm here if you if you need someone i'm
here you know would love to walk with
you in this and then she may be more
receptive the other thing zach um and
and dave talked about this but uh
you may not your brother may not listen
we can talk to him you want to help your
mom talk to him and get him out
like you you are exactly what you said
dave you are a burden
you need to be on your own
you need to get your own place it's
gonna make a lot easier to take care of
mom and help mom
if you're not having to deal with all
that you and said wife need to be
working 60 hours a week and being on
your own and then me and my wife me and
myself are going to help mom as well to
the extent mom will let us yeah
but we're not going to be a burden on
her anymore
and um you know and it sounds like some
stuff's gonna have to be sold to clean
up the mess would you you know and it's
a dumpy place and they want to get out
of there sell it and go rent something
but you know go rent a little uh
two-bedroom apartment for her and your
little brother
and um that'll give your older brother
or your middle brother a reason to leave
yeah because there's not a place for him
at the new place
but again
your mom if she's going to stiff-arm you
and play the the tough independent i
don't need help
uh john wayne routine there's nothing
you can do
all you can do is what christy said just
continually say i'm here when you want
help i will tell you what will drive her
nuts and you nuts is either you forcing
yourself into a situation where you're
not welcome or
she gives you only a little bit of
information and you try to act on that
and so you're playing around the edges
and you can't really get to the core of
the problem and that's not gonna do
anything but frustrate her and you
so if you if you're gonna help it needs
to be all in
if you're gonna stand on the sidelines
it needs to be all the way on the
sidelines
and that's the best way you can help her
and serve her in this situation i'm so
sorry you guys are facing this
what a scary time for your family just
lots of hugs lots of grace because
people don't always act right when
they're under this much stress
this
is the ramsey show
[Music]
hey it's kelly associate producer for
the ramsay show
this episode is over but if you heard
about an event product or service and
didn't have a chance to write it down
don't worry we list everything you've
heard about during this episode in the
podcast show notes section or head to
the ramsay show.com thanks for listening
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw as the status symbol of
choice i am dave ramsey your host thank
you for joining us america christy
wright ramsey personality number one
best-selling author is my co-host today
open phones at
825-5225
one week from christie's book launch we
are here
the new book take back your time the
guilt-free guide to life balance will be
shipped to your homes for those of you
that have bought it and it'll be there
by one week from today
and so that means for those of you that
have not yet bought the book and that's
not many of you because it sounds like
looking at the numbers most of you've
already bought one but there's a few of
them left and we can get some more so uh
go ahead and get your purchase in
because if you buy before the actual
launch date yes save oh well you spend
the same 20 but you get a lot more for
it you get everything ebook audiobook a
ticket to our take back your time live
event on
uh thursday night next week and that's
the 16th and uh and and it's going to be
one of those things where afterwards
you're going to wish you did because
then you you would have had all those
bonus items so don't wait until launch
week go ahead and get it now it'll ship
very soon you'll get it next week and uh
and have the e-book audio book as well
yeah and you're gonna get uh
and again a ticket to the live event
christy will be doing i'll be a a guest
on the live event and we want you guys
to come and check it out take back your
time
the guilt-free guide to life balance is
the new book one week from today
uh again for 20 bucks you can get close
to 100 worth of items
and it's a pretty cool purchase price
pretty cool deal and this is the book
where um
you're learning the step-by-step plan to
be intentional
with your time where you can actually
work on really what matters and it does
do away with the guilt the getting rid
of the guilt is a big deal around this
because um
you know burnout is really not from hard
work yeah
yeah and it's interesting because you've
talked about this from the entrepreneur
space but i've seen it even with with
anything in business or in life
we say oh i really want to do this but i
never have the time to or oh this is
really important to me but i can never
fit it on my schedule if there's a gap
between what's deeply important to you
and what you actually spend your time on
in business or in life you're going to
be stressed and frustrated and anxious
and dave you've heard me talk about this
for over a decade what i want to do is
help people bridge that gap where you
are doing the right things at the right
time and it turns out
it's not about productivity when you do
the right things the right time you
actually feel that sense of balance
you've been looking for but it's not
because you did everything perfectly for
an equal amount of time it came from
simply doing the right things and so i
lay out a five-step plan in the book
decide what matters stop doing what
doesn't matter create a calendar that
reflects what matters
protect what matters and be present for
what matters and when you do that in any
new season you will be doing the right
things at the right time and you will be
creating your version of balance which
is the only version of balance that
should matter to you anyway so it's very
customizable i want to help you figure
this out what life balance means to you
and help you achieve it and it turns out
that's uh that's what leads to that
feeling we've been wanting all along and
it can be a positive thing or a negative
thing that's driving it but the extremes
teach us the principle i was thinking
about you in this book this weekend um
we have some friends our age in their
60s their their grown daughter your age
uh rachel's age is um in icu she's very
ill
and um
you know what they're working on
nothing that's right except they're
taking care of her kids her family her
husband they're there at the hospital
when they can be in there um they're not
they're they're not doing anything and
the crisis situation like that has
you know is are they out of balance no
that's what's right they're doing what's
right that's exactly right they're
perfectly in balance there's nothing
else going on in their life yeah they're
not on vacation
they're not nurturing their pet right
they're not doing all these you know
they're not they're probably not uh
attending church they're probably not
going to the gym right you know they're
doing one thing right now and the
extremes illustrate the point that you
when you work on what's right
you're not out of balance no and it's so
interesting too because this book and
every
all of my teaching around this topic
which is a topic that is so full of
shame it's so full of guilt of you
should be doing this more it should be
doing this morning just we don't know
what balance is we just know we don't
have it so we're nagged by this this
shadow that haunts us but what's
interesting is
when you do the right things at the
right time when when you think about
what that is and you do it
you shake the guilt for all the things
you're not doing for all the things that
are not right right now so i'm not gonna
feel bad for not working out not working
not having a clean house because i'm
taking care of my child in the hospital
when you bring back to front and center
and full focus of what is right right
now it gives you permission to focus on
it but it also helps you shake the guilt
of all the things that are not right
right now and that's powerful in our
very distracted
over-committed culture that's a huge uh
that's freeing that's a message of
freedom for people that feel over
committed yeah i think you and i
discovered last um
last hour that that when people attempt
balance with the wrong approach they
basically joined the circus yeah i love
how you said that because all the
analysis yeah they're plates spinning
they're juggling and they're tight rope
walking yeah and these are these are all
the metaphors we use for balancing i can
i play spin i juggle
flaming swords
while walking a tightrope so this book
is about getting out of the circus
you've joined the circus
you need to quit the circus it's like
juggle faster no just get out of the
tent you don't want your life to be a
circus these analogies are terrible it's
a sign that we're asking the wrong
question so i love that analogy it's so
true not my monkey not my circle this is
the answer to getting back in balance
that's right i don't have to deal with
that over there that is not my monkey
not my circus you people go deal with
your stuff i'll be over here dealing
with mine it's a full-time job
oh my goodness yeah that's another thing
get shadow balances when you start
managing other people's lives we need to
get henry cloud in here and talk about
boundaries boundaries well step four in
the path it's five steps step four is
protect what matters
and i quote him obviously he is the
expert on boundaries but saying no and
you and i've talked about this a lot and
setting boundaries what's interesting is
it helps you protect those things on
your calendar that matter to you it
helps you protect them from outside
people that might want to chip away and
tell you what you should be doing
also helps you protect it from yourself
and getting distracted by oh i want to
do this and squirrel and this person oh
no no sometimes just having those
boundaries help you protect the
outsiders and even you from yourself to
protect that balance that you can work
so hard to create yeah and i'll i'll
help you with this um
saying no is a muscle that can be built
yes and and my no muscle is really
strong you don't flinch i don't
understand
but you know what it comes from not
having one yeah it comes from uh you
know having my life overrun by other
people's agendas
and somebody's gonna be mad at me
because i won't go to this event and
speak on this weekend right which by the
way happens to be the weekend that my my
high school daughter is going on a prom
right well i just chose her over you
deal with it yeah and um but they get
mad and write hate mail letters and
dave's gotten too big for his britches
and i remember when dave ramsey used to
be nice no you don't cause it never
happened
okay so shut up winer but oh my gosh
that's that's a fun i love that hate
mail it's like dave has changed so much
no he really hasn't you can even be nice
when you say it and it does get easier
the more you practice the easier it
becomes but you got to practice to get
good at it yeah and i should practice on
the nice part you should but i'll help
you with the not nice part the no i'm
really good at it just like now
and you know it keeps it keeps a lot of
margin in your life you got a wiggle
room to do all kinds of stuff when you
just go i can't do that i'm sorry no
sorry
sorry not sorry
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
still on baby step number one huh
how'd you guess
with health care costs rising learn how
christian healthcare ministries can help
you make the most out of your budget
visit chministries.org
budget don't worry
it's worth it
[Music]
[Music]
christy wright ramsey personality is my
co-host today here on the ramsey show
open phones as we talk about your life
and your money dalton is in atlanta
georgia hi dalton how are you
good dave how are you doing better than
i deserve man what's up in your world
well i was just calling i have a couple
questions i've been listening to a few
years podcast and i just figured why not
call in
so cool i am 22 years old and i've been
working for the well since i was 19. i
went to school for welding
and i've been traveling the tri-state
area where i live for the past almost
three years
well sometimes nineteen so two three
years and uh i've
saved up almost ninety thousand dollars
wow wow
good for you
yeah what kind of money are you making a
year as a welder
um close to if i work i work outages and
sometimes it's uh iffy like you work a
few months here a few months there but
on
of average from 80 to 100 000 a year
good for you well done the trades pay
well you're working a lot of hours it's
hard work but you're making good money
right
yes yeah yeah i mean when you're when
you're on you're working that's tough
work but uh
and so you're working power stuff huh
yeah nuclear mostly i've worked in uh
live nuclear plants and building nuclear
plants
okay wow wow
yeah you're really building a resume
there that's pretty impressive good and
you got 85 000 and are you living at
home are you are you living in a camper
i mean what are you doing
i recently just bought a camper about a
month ago and before that i was living
with a
high school friend that i went to
welding school with in his camper and
then before that i had rented an
apartment which was one of my worst
mistakes but you live in new orleans
yeah because you're never there
yeah exactly
a lot more i could have paid for a
camper for when i paid rent in that
apartment yeah so you so you're going to
suv i mean as you you're going to
winnebago at a round or whatever while
you uh whatever the brand is while you
uh run this circuit for a while at this
stage of your life how long do you think
you're going to live that life
well that's what i was asking i was
recently um engaged in this bias because
i was talking to
um a person i knew that has only owned
the business and ray told me well if you
don't want to travel all the time why
don't you buy like a service truck and
open your own business and so i was just
going to ask you if you what you thought
about that idea or how much money you
think
you would have to have saved up to start
your own business
as a welding business enough to buy the
supplies
in the truck
okay you can outfit this truck for 50
grand right
yes or less yeah yeah yeah because you
don't want a fancy truck it's going to
be hauling a bunch of junk around
yeah yeah i mean it is it's welding
equipment it's your trade but it's not
this is not a you don't need you don't
need a
something from a chevy commercial i mean
this is this is a work truck right
exactly and so uh i love that idea
so what i would tell you if you're my 22
year old son is that running a business
is different than running an arc welder
okay so you have the skills to be a
welder you do not have the skills yet to
run a business
okay and much like you had to learn how
to weld you're going to learn how to run
a business
and so you've got to start thinking
about what it takes to operate a
business
not just perform the task
okay so i mean buying a truck and
getting the welding gear yeah and can
you do the job once you've got the job
yeah but you have to price it you have
to collect it you have to pay your taxes
you have to get new customers you have
to take care of the existing customers
and now you're running a business
yes and so i you know and it it is at
least as difficult to run a business
with a service truck like that as it is
to weld the other thing dalton is and
don't let that discourage you because
the day-to-day will still be the welding
work
your day-to-day will still be doing the
work you know how to do and you love how
to do but there will be a learning curve
where you figure out how are you going
to price this how are you going to
manage the money how are you going to
interact with customers with clients and
and
and even points of contact like the
really tactical stuff that you probably
don't deal with day to day and you
haven't even thought about in terms of
your business some of this is as simple
as talking to someone who's running a
business as as doing a google search is
just putting some of your notes and
ideas on paper start to just
let this idea simmer in your mind and
capture your thoughts in a notebook or
something really basic this does not
have to be sophisticated and it doesn't
have to overwhelm you
once you get through this learning curve
of learning some of the basic business
setup and the basic business operations
you will spend the vast majority of your
time 80 to 90 of your time doing the
welding work especially out of the gate
because that's that's you know in the
initial stages that you just own your
job that's what you're doing but you do
need to just think about some of these
things and and learn some of these
things and uh and if you start doing
that you could make even more money
doing this i want you to find a 35 year
old guy that's running a truck
and doing welding
and making a good living
and i want you to go take a day or two
or next time you've got some down time i
want you to go spend three days with him
take your camper take your camper go
hang out in that city where he could be
two cities over five cities over i don't
care maybe he's over at dallas you're
mobile you run over there from it you
run over there from atlanta spend two or
three days with him and i want you to go
to school not on welding
on running a business
how do you run a business what did you
not know what do i need to know how do
you do your pricing where do your
customers come from and i want you to
take like some yellow pads or an ipad or
something i want you to fill up files
and thousand thousand files of the
answers of an actual practitioner in
that world
and so you know when you first learned
the weld they showed you that someone
showed you by welding you watched them
weld
right
yes you're exactly very first class and
then you tried it
and then they helped you by letting you
watch the then you watched it again and
then you tried it again until finally
that thing would quit sticking and it
would actually create an arc right
exactly and um so
well maybe you're doing a settling i
don't know but um but anyway
the metaphor still stands so uh
yeah you go stud you go study someone
else and then you do it and then you
study someone else and then you do it
and then you study someone else and and
your first step is to get the business
up and running and then your next step
is to grow the business to where it's
not to where you own more than just your
job your first goal in business is at
least own your own job
and when you if you don't work if you
don't go to work you don't get paid
that's owning your own job right but if
you got five people working for your
welding and six trucks out there
now you own a business that if you don't
work one day they all still work
and that's that's growing into the next
level but i don't want to go too fast
here you're 22 you got plenty of time
yes i would buy a service truck and yes
i would go into business if you have
that desire but go study business from a
couple people i'm going to give you a
copy of our number one best-selling book
uh entree leadership which is how it's
our playbook on how we started this
business and how we ran it and run it
and it'll give you some good guidelines
on how to get there dalton i want to
give you a couple questions too to ask
these people that you're going to study
and shadow and learn from one ask them
what did you learn the hard way
another uh another way to ask it is what
did you wish you knew when you got
started
and another thing to ask them are what
are the biggest trip ups i should look
out for like customers or problems or
things that man that that just you know
might be a potential landmine that you
don't even know how can you learn about
that before you get into it ask some of
those questions to get some of those
learnings without you having to learn
the hard way yourself and they'll tell
you uh they'll they'll show you and you
can you can avoid that going out you
know out of the gate i love that what a
great young guy mm-hmm that's cool we've
talked about making great 22 year olds
in the last couple hours they're doing
pretty impressive stuff yeah so there's
hope america
there's hope the next generation coming
on there's some good ones in the bunch
there's a bunch of good ones in the
bunch and um no bunch has all good ones
the bunch has all bad ones but this
bunch has got some really good ones
that's pretty cool and the trades uh
well with this uh epic student loan
debacle yeah that we have uh in higher
education the trades are coming back on
with a gale force wins everybody's
moving into the trades i mean when you
can with a high school education at 22
for the last four years while his
friends were in college making nothing
he's made a hundred thousand dollars a
year
[Music]
he's doing okay he's 400 grand ahead
before they got started
very interesting
very interesting
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners we're
intentional about choosing the best
advertisers to recommend blinds.com is
no exception they offer high quality
window treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering free shipping and a
guaranteed perfect fit go to blinds.com
and take advantage of this week's
special savings
[Music]
chrissy wright ramsey personality is my
co-host today in the lobby of ramsey
solutions on the debt-free stage zayn
and megan are with us hey guys how are
you good we're doing good welcome where
do you guys live uh springfield illinois
oh fun welcome to nashville and all the
way here to do a debt-free scream how
much did you pay off we paid off 79 000
all right awesome how long did this take
uh two years in three months
all right and your range of income
during that time we started at 64 000
and ended up just over 92 000. awesome
what do y'all do for a living i'm a hair
stylist and an educator at the color
company we go through
and i just got a new job last week i'm
going to be a energy sales specialist
all right very cool good for you guys
what kind of debt was the 79 000 um a
little bit of everything credit card
debt um car loans personal loans student
loans our house our house yep you paid
off your house yeah oh goodness good at
weird people wow
casually oh
no
way to go wow how long you guys been
married um about four and a half years
now yeah okay so about two years in the
marriage this journey starts what made
you decide to get on this journey
i was driving home my water truck and i
was flipping through the radio and heard
about you oh my gosh just like that
the the random scan of the radio one of
my best promotional tricks so random
yeah i will have to say though um
when we first got married for the first
about year and a half of our
relationship we kept everything separate
and
he would try to get me to pay off my
debt and he was already doing it and i
just thought it was really dumb i didn't
think we could go through life without
buying a car without a loan buying a
house without a loan really doing
anything without putting ourselves in
debt first so it took him a really long
time
of keep trying to be like oh we should
do this we should do this and i was like
no i'm not about that i'd rather spend
my money
i don't want to be told what to do
and then it came to a point where i was
out shopping one day and i went to go
supply buy supplies for work and my
my debit card
got denied
and so then i had to use my credit card
which also worried me because i knew at
the time it was almost maxed out as well
and i was like
maybe zayn knows what he's talking about
and
so i came home and i was like i
reluctantly too it's a really hard thing
for me to ever admit
dosa crow right yeah
i started listening to the podcast on my
own before i would even honestly admit
that i was even thinking about it
because i'm super stubborn and i was not
about it wasn't about him
right and so finally i was like it's a
sneaky podcast
maybe maybe we should start looking into
it and i just thought it was like i just
said yes to marry him all over again oh
wow so you did the little snoopy dance
and everything huh wow i was pretty
happy about that i'm thinking yeah oh my
gosh well i mean you get a double bonus
one you get to be right
the best part it doesn't happen very
often and two she's gonna do that money
thing wow this is awesome
this is a good day yeah i have very much
the free spirit in this relationship and
uh you are fun yeah so it was really
hard and it was something i was like
okay but to do this i need at least like
a little bit of leeway so i had at least
in my budget
a little bit of spending money for
myself because i was like even if it's
just like a top here or like a pair of
shoes there but i've got to do something
to keep my sanity otherwise it's just
not gonna ideally work out for me he he
could never spend a dime in his life and
be okay i i love this story and i love
your honesty megan i have a theory dave
you tell me if i'm wrong here i have a
theory that we often see obviously in
marriages there's a nerd and a free
spirit but we often see that one spouse
is reluctant to get on board and my
theory is the reluctant spouse is always
the free spirit you never see the nerd
going i don't know i don't know about
this budget i don't know about the
saving money thing oh it's the spender
it's me it's you it's all the free
spirits going no don't tell don't box me
in don't tell me what to do don't give
me rules i love that you came around
though well done yeah like it took him a
long time
took him a while but he stayed
persistent and it was never like pushy
about it was just like well i'm already
doing it and then he had also paid off a
vehicle by himself doing it and i was
kind of like oh like and i got money
i was really nervous too about
putting our bank accounts together just
because i did spend so much more money
and i
still have
but then when you do come to the
realization of we're in a marriage not
we're not roommates it does make a lot
difference and honestly when we did put
our bank accounts together it made me
not want to spend as much money too it
made me be a lot more conscious about my
purchases
let's talk about that megan because
there are people listening right now
there are couples listening that they
haven't put their money together yet
what would you say to them i just think
it's crazy i don't know i just found
that once we put our bank accounts
together that we got a lot closer with
each other too and it just it opens up a
lot more honesty and i never felt like
i've never felt like i've had to hide my
purchases but even more so i never
felt guilty about buying something
because it's all laid out right there in
front of you and i just don't understand
why you wouldn't hear it so did you guys
feel like you were more of a team when
you put those together yes 100 it's
really cool and there for a while we had
what we thought worked for us uh you
know i paid this bill you paid that bill
i'll buy groceries at the store you buy
groceries at that store
and then it it did just get to a point
of
yeah why aren't we we're married why why
do we feel the need to keep our stuff
separate when a marriage means you know
unity yeah that's good usually usually
the continued separation once you have
that question pop into your head is
shame or control
and zane's not a control freak no and so
uh he that helped you know and once you
decided that it was you shaming you not
zane absolutely and you cannot be
ashamed and just go it's my money i can
do what i want to do with it and i
actually as rachel says it's a spending
plan yes whenever
i still i had all the credit cards and
i just remember like right before we
were getting ready to go to the bank to
combine our accounts i was like i kind
of feel like i should pay these off i
don't know if i want them to know how
much credit card debt i've racked up and
we were sitting down to dinner and i'm
just sitting there and i was like you
know
i
i have to i gotta get this off my chest
i just have to tell you this but i have
i i believe at the time it was like
sixty four hundred dollars in credit
card debt and i was like
i i've gotta tell you this i was gonna
try i did i don't know where i thought i
was gonna pay this off by myself is that
all
he was like i thought you were going to
tell me so much more than that
i told you he was he was like because i
was like i just i've got to tell you
this like i'm so nervous this is going
to be bad it's going to be 40 grand it
was like oh well that's no big deal
we've got it
that's awesome i love you too oh you
guys are great
so how old are you two i'm 28. i'm
almost 27. all right and you have a paid
for house that's worth how much um
give or take 75.80 wow
you're so weird
you're awesome yeah you guys are a power
couple you're so fun this is so great
you've done such a great job and
everything in your relationships in in
your self-awareness in the whole process
that you use what happened here to you
personally and to you as a couple is
even more important than what happened
with the money so you guys are this very
very cool story i love it it's very very
fun
79 000 paid off house and everything you
don't have a payment in the world making
almost a hundred thousand not even 30
years old
how's that feel amazing yeah it's really
awesome too just to know that we're
really going to set ourselves up in the
future and someday when we have kids
it'll be really nice to not really have
any worries about
are we going to be able to afford to do
this and that with them it'll be very
nice to be able to set up their future
as well and teach them about money
that's awesome well done you guys yeah
we got a copy of the legacy journey for
you because that is the next chapter in
your story
move on to set that legacy up like
you're talking about
and uh be baby steps millionaires you'll
be there before you know it absolutely
incredible and a copy of the total money
makeover for you to give away to
somebody who's out there doing it wrong
because uh because the stuff we teach is
too dumb
i love it
that's just awesome
so fun so fun well done zayn and megan
springfield illinois oh man 79 000 paid
off house and everything in two years
and three months making 64-92 count it
down let's hear a debt-free scream three
two one we're debt-free
yeah
i love it that is fun that's awesome
they are great
oh man what a future
and really good insights yeah i love
that great storytelling well done
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
thanks for joining us america christie
wright ramsey personality is my co-host
today open phones at
825-5225 you jump in we'll talk about
your life your money dawn is with us in
williamsport up whoops i hit the wrong
button of course williamsport
pennsylvania hi don how are you
well hello you two i'm better than i
deserve and i hope you're the same we
also love it how can we help wonderful
well my husband and i we're also weirdos
uh we're debt-free
we are putting in an offer on a house we
are paying in cash
and
seems like everyone
is trying to sell us on these
conventional renovation loans now we're
new to being weird but i'm not keen on
the word alone can you tell me a little
bit about these and what's the deal
there
well it's just simply buying a house
that's messed up and you're borrowing
the money for the house and the rehab
gotcha that's all it is i mean it's just
a conventional rehab loan that's all it
is and so you're you're able to borrow
uh more than the purchase price which on
a typical mortgage it's called a
purchase money mortgage on a typical
mortgage you can only buy up to the
purchase price
but in this case they'll loan you the
renovations as well uh up to a certain
point above the actual price but you
have the cash to do all of this
yes
okay you have the cash for the
renovation as well not just the purchase
price
yes we do uh-huh
well there's not a question not any
question that's what you should do then
i don't care what everyone says everyone
is stupid broke and divorced
i mean my god you know why do we want
all these losers i mean people are just
messed up and they all have an opinion
you know so no i'm not taking broke
people's advice on getting everyone gets
a loan no they don't did you know 25 of
americans own a paid for house
so it's really not as weird as we make
it out to be
now when somebody does it at under 30
years old like our last debt free scream
that's pretty cool
but it's not that weird and and by the
way uh only about 60 or 55 of americans
own a home
the other 45 rent
or own a modular home or something like
that a mobile home something like that
but a traditional home is 55 to 60 and
25
is paid for so almost half the people
that own a home
paid for it in america but nobody talks
about that yeah so yeah don i don't know
who you're listening to but you probably
need to not listen to them on that
subject
typically the people already knew the
answer
typically the people trying to tell you
you have to get this that or the other
are the people that have some skin in
the game or some agenda or some
commission or something it may not be
that in this case but you've got the
cash you just go with your gut you knew
exactly what you needed to do and in
your own point you're you're on the
target with that dawn has a special loan
it's called i paid for it no loan
yeah that's a new program that's out
there and it's sweeping the nation
rachel's with us in tulsa oklahoma hi
rachel how are you
i'm doing okay thank you dave for taking
my call sure what's up
yeah so i am a 28 year old and just
graduated with my bachelor's degree in
leadership you're you're 21 year old say
that again
28 28 years old okay
yes and i graduated with my bachelor's
in leadership studies i made about
thirty thousand and i'm 120 000 in debt
i've tried to make a budget but it's not
working so
seeking your advice what do you mean
it's not working
my income is
some days some weeks i get overtime and
sometimes i don't so my income is just
it's not fair
so setting the budget is really
difficult
okay well there's a way to budget for
irregular income but it sounds like to
me it's it's more of a problem than just
that
do you just not are you not able to make
your bills on your income
barely yeah
what do you do
i work for um i'm in retail
i work at autozone okay and you got a
degree for 120 000 in leadership studies
well that in car loan and medical debt
credit card how much of the 120 is
student loans
100 of it okay
all right so what is the game plan to
put that education to work to make more
than 30k at
autozone
i am trying to
you know put my resume out and get into
the field
just there's been no you know my resume
hasn't got any hits on it for interviews
okay what are you what are you applying
for
any job that comes up
okay
rachel i i hear in your voice and maybe
i'm wrong here but i hear in your voice
that it sounds like you are taking a a
more passive approach to this job search
than i want you to
you have to get your income up
significantly
if you're going to get out of 120 000 in
debt so that could be working three
retail jobs or you could just land a
really good job and then maybe some
extra sidekicks uh that gets your income
up but it's going to take
knocking the door down it's gonna take
i'm going to email you my resume i'm
going to apply online i may hand deliver
a resume on beautiful resume paper as
well and bring you some coffee while i'm
at it like you are going to find the
people that you want to work with using
the skills that you have the the
connections you want to make the
companies that you want to work for i
don't know what it looks like but you
have got to get scrappy and determined
to get your foot in the door a job is
not going to appear on your lap
so
someone lied to you
they told you that if you went and got a
degree in leadership studies
that someone would hire you to be a
leader
and i know i have to work you know start
at the bottom yeah and that was that was
a lie
and then the second thing so what you're
going to need to do is narrow your focus
in on what you want to be
doing when you're 38 what does a decade
from now rachel look like
and then what are the steps for me to
get there the leadership degree in
leadership studies is not a bad degree
it just doesn't come with a guarantee of
prosperity
or a guarantee that it's going to
automatically open up the resume door in
a digital world so let me give you a
couple things one is i'm going to give
you ken coleman's book
the proximity principle
and he ken does a show here at the
ramsey networks on finding a job and
finding a career and getting plugged
into your career also i want you to go
to kencoleman.com i want you to download
all of his resume templates and all of
his free tools he's got a ton of stuff
there that's going to help you get your
foot in the door
somewhere doing one specific type of
thing if you just say i'll work anywhere
that pays more money no one will hire
you i don't want to hire you if that's
your goal if i'm an employer i'll hire
300 people here this year and i won't
hire you to do anything that makes more
money than autozone i don't have a job
description that's that
i have a job description that says i
need this certain thing done can you do
this certain thing and are you
passionate about this certain thing oh
by the way 300 people will get hired 24
000 applications will come in digitally
so guess what you got no chance
just filling out applications
zero chance
you could be the daughter of the
president of the united states and
you've got zero chance getting 500 300
out of 24 000. you have to do something
else that sets yourself apart in this
world you can't just monster.com your
way into this it doesn't work
and so um you got to get somebody inside
the building that is at the place that
you want to work doing the thing that
you want to do that gets your foot in
the door i had a young lady apply here
uh for a marketing position two weeks
ago and within 48 hours i had four of my
friends email me and say hey so-and-so's
daughter has applied there please get
her name out of the stack
now i didn't hire her because of that
but it got her an interview
and it got her past the stack
and i don't even know if we hired her
yeah and i truthfully i
i don't tell my guys they have to hire
somebody it's a daughter or my friend or
whatever but i do want them to at least
give her a look out of as a courtesy and
if they're friends of christie's they're
going to get a look at a courtesy of
their friends at kelly's are going to
get a look out of courtesy and that
doesn't mean we're going to hire them
but it gets you out of the 24 to 300
stack you know that's how i got here i
applied for a position 12 years ago in
our event team and got an auto response
that position had been filled started
reaching out to anybody that i knew that
worked here or anybody that you knew
that knew somebody that's right and
started having a conversation after
conversation that led to a job posting
that led to what i'm doing you've got to
get more determined you got to get more
determined rachel if you're going to get
a job you've got it's not going to
that's what i mean by somebody lied to
you you made you think this was going to
be easy
um it's not it's going to be really hard
it's just going to be worth it hang on
kelly i'll pick up we'll send you a copy
of ken coleman's book and we'll help you
with this get on his website start
listening to ken coleman podcast i think
magically you will get a job if you'll
do exactly the stuff he tells you to do
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
dave here we just launched a brand new
listener survey we want to know what you
think about the show you'll be entered
to win a 100 amazon gift card no
purchase necessary take the survey at
ramseysolutions.com survey or text
survey to 33 789
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw as the status symbol of
choice i'm dave ramsey your host kristy
wright ramsey personality is my co-host
today open phones at triple eight eight
two five five two two five
those of you who are enjoying
the last bits of fall freedom here um we
want you to come to nashville and enjoy
our new not our new but our ongoing
business boutique event
it will be here very very soon and i'm
scrambling here looking for the date as
i said october 14th through the 16th
october 14th through the 16th there we
go
and uh christy wright along with me and
who all speaking so we've got jasmine
starr who is an expert on social media
she's spoken before always a huge hit
nona jones bianca oltof monique shohan
and uh dr john deloney in addition to
you and i and what i think people need
to know if you're if you're thinking
about attending this event which by the
way you could come to nashville come
live stream however you want to do it
but we cover the topics that you need
help with the most that's how we build
this event is based on your surveys
based on your feedback these are the
things i need help with marketing sales
money management time management pushing
past your fear so those are the topics
that we hire and book speakers based on
so it's not just the name it's also the
topic that you need help with so you
walk out of there with the tactical
action items of what you need to do to
grow your business but also man we fire
you up we want to get you like you said
what did you say a couple uh hours ago
that a syringe of courage i help you
believe that you can do it because then
that changes your actions when you go
home and so the combination's really
powerful yeah
well people need a syringe full of
courage right
there's a lot of there's a lot of fear
out there and a lot of different reasons
and uh this event is going to be
absolutely incredible business boutique
equipping women to make money doing what
they love it comes from the number one
best-selling book business boutique but
it also comes from years of doing this
event it's always a sellout it's always
a big party everyone i mean 98 of the
attendees are ladies and it is uh
absolutely a blast to speak to
and to be a part of and you will leave
not only with information but you'll
leave with the inspiration to go home
and and start that business and get the
things going and like i tell you coming
out of 2020 um
even
seasoned business people
uh are uh we we have a kind of fatigue
uh a little bit of a cloud
over the future yeah over our hope over
our heads and i fight through it
everybody fights through it but um
it's a it's a real thing and
i i would hate to think
that your idea because it was still
just coming through the ground just a
tender
little beginner idea
gets squashed by kovitt yeah and it's
interesting because there's something
really powerful certainly if you want to
join us on live stream let's find that
there's something powerful about being
in that room
being around
two thousand other business women other
women chasing their dreams that the
momentum
and the energy
is so powerful you literally take it
home with you and so i just i can't
encourage you enough to come in the room
and by the way you mentioned david's 98
women which it is uh but if you're a man
listening right now
and you have a wife a mom a daughter
that has a side business buy this for
her because there is such a pattern
tickets are only what 89 bucks or
something i think it's like 129 129
but it's interesting because so many
women end up in the room because their
husband or their dad or their son bought
them a ticket sometimes women especially
when they're starting out in business
i was looking at a lady's event the
other day it was 1200 bucks yeah yeah
it's unbelievable so text boutique to 33
789 to get tickets uh it's october 14th
through the 16th here in nashville it'll
be here in 20 minutes that's gonna
happen really fast that's about a month
away is all yeah okay so you can still
get tickets you can still get hotel
rooms you can still enjoy nashville it's
a three-day event and it is completely
full you will leave uh both excited and
exhausted yeah
from the event and um you know plan an
extra day or two on one side of this and
enjoy nashville while you're here it's
one of the premier cities in america
right now so text boutique
23789 october 14 through the 16. jd is
with us in lincoln nebraska hi jd how
are you
wonderful how are you guys better than i
deserve what's up
well i'm one of the few that you have
talked about that has inherited
millions
i wish
turned me into a millionaire
but i own
one of a piece of property that
i would like to
sell
either to the partnership that already
exists and let them own it or
have the have the whole thing liquidated
and turn it into put my portion into
mutual funds
because i don't see the return that i
would like to see off of the piece of
property but i don't know that i can
make it work
and i'm just looking for guidance okay
um so the the partners that are in this
or your other relatives that inherited
it with you
correct okay and how many of them are
there
um there are two others uh but we are
not equal owners um my uncle and i are
larger share owners than my
other aunt
and what what percentage do you own
41
okay and how is this structured um is it
an llc or do each of you just
individually own a portion
no it is an llc okay does the llc uh
documents allow for sale of shares
as long as all three parties agree
okay all right
so
how is the relationship with your uncle
and your aunt
uh the relationship is good i don't know
if the
uh interest to buy me out will be there
um i have been told that to sell the
this piece of property it would have to
bring
a certain dollar amount and i don't know
that we're there
to sell it outright for that
okay
well i think i'd start the conversation
with them and just say i'm one out i
went out it's no disrespect to you all
or to the family or to the person who
left it to me there's no disrespect to
the memory of what's going on it's an
investment decision for me and i want
out i want to sell my 41 percent now how
are we going to do this
do you guys want to put the whole thing
on the market or can i discount it
and let youtube buy me out or one of you
buy me out and i would discount it uh
reasonably it's found money you didn't
quote unquote earn it i don't want you
to cut it in half but if you you know
what is your 41 approximately worth
about 590 000 okay and so if you got 490
for it i wouldn't be mad
okay i just made that up
but i mean
my point is a substantial discount but
not a huge huge huge thing so if you
guys will get me out i'll give you a
deal
because i need to move on
this is the right thing to do and i
don't think you guys want to sell it
based on the price you think you can get
that you want to demand for it that's
the signal you don't really want to sell
it because it's not going to bring that
and i want out
and so let's start a conversation how
how we can get me out do we sell it
or do i discount it to you guys and let
you guys buy me out how can we work this
out let's start to talk about it and i
think you'll see what's going on
this
is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
christy wright ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
if you're like most people you've got
more than enough on your mind right now
getting kids where they need to be
keeping up with the bills staying on top
of work and family it's exhausting and
stressful money does not have to be one
more thing you worry about
when you have the right plan
you can be in control with your money
and consequently it affects being in
control of your life
we teach you that plan in a thing called
financial peace
university we've taught almost 10
million people that plan
in fpu financial peace university the
class shows you step by step how to pay
off debt
save money
and become wealthy in the future
and outrageously generous
you can stream all nine lessons on your
own or and or you can join a class with
other people so you're not figuring out
a lot figuring it out alone and right
now the only way to experience fpu
is with a ramsey plus membership
the plan works every time
if you work it
ask the millions who've done it they
don't worry about money anymore
and you can do it too you can start a
free trial at ramsey plus and see what
i'm talking about
text trial to 33
789
that's trial two three three
seven
eight nine
chris is with us in san antonio hi chris
welcome to the ramsey show
hey how you doing sir great man what's
up
hey listen we uh we started working the
baby steps we
which i'm really grateful we ended up we
tested positive had to go on the bubble
for a couple weeks
and they're kind of when our emergency
phone which you know hey that's where
what it was for but i was kind of
offering i want to ask you about this
are
we were
honestly and this is part of my fault we
were right up to like that 30 day mark
with our mortgage as far as being late
um
and before we hit it you know which that
was i was wanting to get a caught up
here pretty quick but covet kind of cut
first
so anyways they
offered me like a forbearance plan and
i'm wondering what your thoughts are on
a forbearance plan
i was applying for it for maybe just
like a month well actually for like two
months just to kind of get past that
little hump
and uh they're like oh man you can take
up to a whole year and i just want to
ask your thoughts on that because they
everything they're giving me they're
like there's no ramifications down the
road that you know
that's why i'm calling you to see what's
going on well um if you don't pay your
payments in a year with their permission
you're aware you have to start paying
those payments and catching all of that
year up later there are ramifications
okay they don't waive the payments for a
year
okay they just delay them so it's like
building a pipe bomb in your basement
you don't know what you're doing
it's eventually going to go off and blow
you up but we're not going to know what
happened because the whole house is
going to cave in on you you know i mean
that's what's going to happen no no no
no no your gut instinct was this is too
good to be true wasn't it
oh yes sir yeah and you're dealing with
somebody on the other end who it has no
ramifications for them at all
but um yeah it definitely has
ramifications because you have to catch
up all those payments someday somehow
somewhere and so the last thing we want
to do because in my head
of course in my head i'm thinking oh
yeah let's let's put this off a couple
more months and now i could pay off
something else but i was like there's
something wrong here you're right you
smelled a rat and you were right you got
rap problems yeah yes sir yeah so no um
and now now let's catch up though and
let's give you a solution that's real
um
because usually the best financial
solutions that are the best ones hurt in
the short term to give you the best
uh outcome in the long term not the
other way around they feel if they feel
good in the short term they almost
always give you a bad outcome in the
long term
and so um it you know so it feels good
to have to skip all those payments right
now but the bad outcome is you got to
make them all up later and it's a
problem it's a ticking time bomb so uh
then on the other hand uh you're how
many payments behind today you owe
august and september
so
i owe like one month and i'm maybe about
halfway you know the two weeks now
you're august first payment
we owe
yes sir the old jew lies
no no okay so august and now september
because september first has passed right
okay so how much is your house payment
it is right about two thousand okay and
are you guys back to work both of you
now
uh yeah i'm the only one working but i i
mean i could get caught up pretty quick
what do you make um
i make
right about a hundred and
it's a little hard to gauge because
everything just kind of started but i'm
gonna say roughly 160. okay have you got
a student loan debt
no okay i have one car payment which
we're about two thousand dollars away
from paying off
that's our second one we we're going to
be able to pay off what are you guys
what do you do chris
uh elevator mechanic and i'm on the
server side of the industry now which i
got you i see why you were out okay
offered a lot of overtime so yeah so can
you get a lot of ot now
oh yeah so you can yeah you can jack it
up in the next 30 days make how much
oh
you you just set my calculator down the
river there that's okay all right i mean
if in 30 days in one month if you worked
all the ot they would give you what do
you think you would make
no i actually went for making before ot
was about nine and then now i'm
calculating i just
what i can you know it's about once
because i've been scooping up pretty
much everything that i could tolerate
you know yeah um okay so here's what i
want you to do i want you to work like
you're losing your house
okay for the next 30 days i want you to
scoop up everybody's overtime yours and
six other peoples i don't want you to
sleep
yeah we had to work i'm handing it over
yeah i want you to work like an absolute
crazy freaking
wild man
because four thousand dollars catches
your house up
six thousand dollars pays off your car
and catches your house up and then you
can rest
because if your house was current and
your car was paid off wouldn't you be a
little bit more relaxed than you are
today
yeah that's worth 30 days of no sleep
that is true okay let's let's pour it on
for 30 days like your freaking life
depends on one more can i throw one more
little thing in the mix because you dug
a little deeper than i was wanting you
to and i feel like i need to ask you
this okay
um i also owe the irs okay and i kind of
i owe them i'm guessing i honestly i
don't even know because during covet it
it was like impossible to try and get a
hold of anybody yeah um i tried and
tried what do you think it is they're
just out too much
what do you think i don't even know i'm
guessing maybe 10 000 maybe okay
after we get the car paid off in the
house caught up here's your first rule
we take care before you do anything else
you take care of what we call the four
walls food
shelter
clothing
transportation and utilities
then we worry about other bills and the
irs will be at the top of the other
bills but they do not come before your
family eating or having the lights on
or
whatever right okay we're going to take
care of your family first and then we're
going to pay the irs right now then
let's go get some ot and knock those
puppies out you do not want those people
in your life
no i don't they they don't mean to be
mean people some of them some of them
mean to be mean people but they're just
this is not they have unlimited power
ridiculous interest rates and penalties
and you want that puppy going as fast as
possible so go ahead and click on
ramseysolutions.com
and go to our website and click on the
endorsed local provider for taxes in
your area and you can get a tax person
to help you navigate first putting the
irs on payments and then secondly i want
them paid off by
into january
[Music]
so no irs no car debt and the house is
current and you're on a budget all by
the end of january
but you're gonna be tired
but you'll be okay
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt free stage brittany is with us hi
brittany how are you i'm great how are
you better than i deserve where do you
live akron ohio wow welcome to nashville
and here to do a debt-free scream how
much have you paid off i paid off 95 000
in 15 months wow good for you and what
kind of how long did that i'm sorry one
more time i'll ask what was the range of
your income during that time um 66 000
to 110. all right good for you 95 000 15
months what kind of debt was the 95 so
the biggest chunk was student loans i
had over 72 000
i had about 10 000 in credit cards 10
000 in a car note
i was making payments on my iphone i was
making payments on her saxophone um
a little bit of everything yeah payments
on the payments on the payments yeah
kind of a great american nightmare
yeah
so uh what in the world happened uh that
started you on this intense journey 15
months ago so it started
to be honest um in like november of
2019 i got a letter saying that my
student loans were about to go back into
payment
and my monthly payment was going to be
more than my rent
um almost 900 a month
and i was intimidated by my 500 car note
so
there was no way
i was going to be able to afford that um
so i was very frightened um that
christmas my mom bought me and my
siblings um
the total money makeover and your
workbook
and it was probably
january or february that i cracked it
open and read it at work
and went through the workbook and
it just
it was like it clicked it all made sense
i started listening to the podcast
all the time there was no radio in the
car the kids got very frustrated with
that
it was the podcast all the time
and the debt free screams there was one
show in particular that you did um
where you talked about because i
couldn't imagine how i was going to
tackle this making 66 000 it was like
there's no way um
and there was one show where you talked
about you got to get a bigger shovel
i was like all right game on
um i got a part-time job i started
picking up all the overtime i could get
i lived at work
i was only home to sleep and eat and
shower
um
yeah i went full we
drank the what is it the kool-aid
thing
so you went for 15 months you just went
crazy yeah
my mom would kind of look at me
occasionally be like why don't you take
a break
there'd be times where i would work you
took that book a little serious yeah i
wouldn't have a day off for like two
three weeks at a time i was working one
or both jobs in one day what is your
main job um i'm a nurse okay and what
was your best uh
best side hustle did you just do more
overtime
so my part-time job i did home care i
work yeah um my full-time job is
inpatient hospital and then i pulled up
home care wow so wow
that's a good good side hustle makes
good money but it's also you're just
working all the time all the time it's
what we were just talking about at these
short-term sacrifices short-term pain
for long-term results and 95
in that income in 15 months is crazy
town what are some of the things you cut
out some sacrifices you made to get it
done to get it finished so quickly so
i'm definitely more of a free spirit
okay um
i made great money and i just never knew
where it went we'd go to the grocery
store we saw something we wanted we
bought it um
go shopping at the store we didn't need
clothes but we bought them
um so it was just like
more discipline for sure we cut out
everything we started shopping at
goodwill the kids didn't get you know
brand new clothes for school we went to
go brand new to us but yeah yeah
experienced clothing right
our kids wore some experience clothing
from consignment shops and you know what
none of them are in counseling because
of it
not to my knowledge anyway they don't
tell me what they say
so you brought the two kiddos with you
and uh what are their names and ages so
this is marguerite she's 13. and my son
casey just turned 9 last month all right
very cool
so how long have you been a single mom
oh goodness um
six seven years okay all right oh wow
wow you are a hero yes you are and you
know who you you know who really knows
you're a hero the one standing to your
right and to your left
they watched mom do what it takes to go
win
in a really tough situation when she was
scared and she went to fight
and she got it done you're amazing yep
they're a good why uh but you you don't
you don't even know what you set in
motion by them watching you do this i
mean christie's mom's a single mom
raised her and uh running a bakery and
the stuff that she learned watching her
mom
by far better than anything i've ever
taught well that's and that's what it
comes down to you didn't you're not
teaching them work ethic and character
and perseverance by sitting them down
and talking about it you're living it
out in front of them and they're picking
up on that and they're gonna have those
character qualities that are forged in
the fire of what's what they've watched
you do but what they've been in it with
you that's what's so key see i think as
parents we want to insulate our kids
from any hardship the fact that they
were at goodwill shopping for clothes
experiencing some sacrifice short term
oh and by the way they're here when she
wins the super bowl that's right on the
stage exactly we're cheering her on
there we got to see that we get to see
the end of the story too
the next chapter in the story it's
absolutely incredible so you're truly a
hero lady
you're amazing you are amazing this is a
great story all right so
single mom with a couple of kiddos is
out there listening right now
and she's scared how does she get out of
debt what's the secret to getting out
i think you need to decide to not be a
victim anymore um my marriage was
abusive and i got a tattoo to remind me
of it and
proverbs 31 25 you know she's closed
with strength and dignity and laughs
without fear of the future and
i decided not to be a victim in my
marriage so why be a victim anywhere
else in my life yeah yeah that's
powerful you're neat
you are so neat i love this lady that's
awesome wow wow
and uh you have uh officially changed
your family tree
uh pretty impressive how's it feel to be
free it's incredible yeah was it worth
all that work oh 100
yeah because now you make 60 to 100
somewhere in there depending on how much
you're gonna make like 130 this year at
least okay without all the ot with with
ot with some ot yeah you don't have to
work as hard you're out no well okay
slow down a little bit that's right baby
step 3b i want to buy a house next year
yeah i know but just it's your band
yeah she's awesome yeah wow get them get
them i love it well done well done well
done
powerful powerful story
and
now it really came down to you just
needed a path and something you believed
in and then you just went all in i just
needed instructions yeah and you just
you just went crazy
just poured it on the poured on gas on
the fire like crazy that's that's
impressive such a heroic thing just very
very well done love it love it love it
love it love it well done well we got a
copy of the legacy journey for you
because you have changed your family
tree and that is the next chapter in
your story you're going to be a baby
steps millionaire one of these days and
i'll be talking to you about that it's
not not not as far off as it might feel
like in your emotions mathematically
you're closer than you think and uh very
very impressive and i'm gonna give you a
copy of the total money makeover so you
can give it away to somebody that you
know
it might be a little scared it might
take them a month to read it then when
they pick it up
maybe they'll get some hope and that's
the idea of paying it forward that's how
we give it to you what we give it to you
for so very very good stuff all right
brittany marguerite and casey from akron
ohio absolute heroes 95 000 paid off in
15 months making 60 to 110. count it
down let's hear a debt free scream ready
three two one we're debt-free
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and the tears running down her
daughter's cheeks say that her daughter
will never be a victim that's right
not a chance and that was the thing not
a chance it wasn't financial it was
you're not a victim
that family tree has changed not a
chance there's a victim in that lineage
not a chance it's changed
wow
this
is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
christie wright ramsey personality is my
co-host today our scripture of the day
is jeremiah 29 13. you will seek me and
find me when you seek me with all your
heart
thomas edison said many of life's
failures are people who did not realize
how close they were to success
when they gave up
that's a sad one right there
i i often wonder the times i quit did i
quit just before
or did i quit like a year too late i
should have quit sooner because it was
not going to work you stupid fool you
know
held on a little too long i always
always get some fun uh feedback on
twitter when i post that quote uh you
know winners never quit yes they do they
quit doing stupid stuff on a regular
basis you know it's just knowing when
when to question what's the stupid stuff
who knew you know i didn't know it was
stupid when i was doing it that's right
by definition bailey is with us bailey
is in fort worth texas hi bailey how are
you
hi dave and christy how are you all
great what's going on
okay so i own a small business that i
opened up earlier this year
i don't have any debt in the business
just my monthly
expenses
and after
paying
for all my big purchases like for
equipment and stuff i have about 6000 in
my business savings
i don't pay myself yet luckily we're
able to live off of my husband's income
and so my plan or our plan was to save
up six months emergency fund for the
business and the business savings and
then i would start paying myself
um but a question that came up
between me and my husband is
we've been paying on uh the only debt we
have for my student loans so we've been
paying on those since it's been zero
interest this whole time which has been
pretty great yeah um we were thinking
should we just
you know back the business savings down
to a thousand and pretty much
pay myself
until they start back up january 31st
and just
hit the student loans hard instead of
what does your husband not
uh he makes almost 90 000. what's your
business
uh chiropractic office
okay
well i'm just thinking through your
expense like what expenses you have you
know because the whole idea of an
emergency fund anyway is for an
emergency i'm trying to think of what
you would potentially even need that for
in order to hold on to any of it
um so
the reason why we're going to do that
first is we are expecting a child at the
end of
january
but
we already have money set aside to where
all of
all of like the delivery and all that
cost is already going to be paid for
so
we did and you don't you don't count on
the income from the chiropractic office
anyway
correct yeah so you're being you're
being off with a baby doesn't hurt that
part of the equation exactly
okay so what is the uh what's the
revenues coming into the chiropractic
office look like today
um
well
a lot like
yeah
yeah your monthly gross
uh last month was 6200
so it's steadily going up like i said i
just opened up
um
earlier this month starting from ground
zero um
but uh and you've already got six
thousand savings
yes sir and that's after buying all my
big equipment yeah okay here we use a
different formula on business with entre
leadership than we in with business
boutique than we do in personal finance
okay what i tell small business owners
is this and then let's adapt that idea
to your situation i tell them to pay
themselves a basic living wage to
support their household
with what's left over after that that
would be called your profit
and that profit can be split between two
things paying off debt in the business
and
uh building up a retained earnings you
don't have any debt
and you but you don't have a ton of
income coming in yet
so
what i would do is start paying yourself
something
okay and then putting the balance
towards
uh retained earnings and so if you said
i'm gonna pay myself
four thousand dollars a month
and i'm gonna put everything else in
retained earnings until i get to six
months once you're at six months i
retain earnings and you have no debt
then there's no reason to keep any more
money in the office unless you in the
business unless you're saving up for a
piece of equipment
okay
but um so i mean you need to start
paying if you're if you're grossing six
grand start paying yourself about four
and let's dump two in there and let's
gradually
and we'll call that a living wage for
today what's the balance on the student
loans
oh my
um chiropractor
but a lot of them are you know just
every trimester i would get a new one so
there's about 20 that build up that and
so you said the total you said the total
is about 200
yes sir okay if i if i pay if you pay
you four for today
it'd be more later as your practice
builds and after the baby and so on but
uh that puts you at 48 plus 90 is 138.
household income okay to attack 200 with
and so um then it depends on how much
you're going to burn the house down at
home in terms of uh scorched earth on
the lifestyle as to how much you throw
back at that but if you throw 75 at it
you're done in three years
okay
out of 138
and um and that's assuming your practice
does not grow at all
of course it's going to grow
yes sir yeah so yeah you just but so i
set a three year or shorter goal for
knocking that out between your income
his income and uh no you don't need to
get any more than six months there and
right now the 6 000 is just fine in this
situation and if you add just a little
bit to it have a formula so you're
adding a little bit to it
and bailey way to go on starting this
business with no debt because so many
people call in this show and they've got
excuse after excuse of why they need
business debt as if it's somehow some
kind of different debt and you didn't do
that you didn't add to your debt uh pile
and you you're gonna knock this out way
to go well done there you go josh is
with us josh is in boise idaho hi josh
how are you
good how are you better than i deserve
what's up
um well i appreciate first of all i
appreciate you taking my call um second
of all
i'll give you a tiny bit of backstory
because i know you're busy
but uh i'm 31 year old male and
i took over my dad's business about in
2009 right before the economy crash um
the whole uh residential crash
and
so when i did that
um we were kind of struggling i took the
business over it's starting to get good
um
but uh i made the mistake of not
educating myself on
uh
taxes
and uh
yes and so what what happened was i had
my old man who i took the
business over from i had him talk me
into having
my sister
do my taxes who was not who is not a cta
and i got audited
and i racked up quite a bit of tax debt
well at the time it was about 15
um thousand yeah um which was kind of
overwhelming for a young person like
myself yeah um i'm now older and i
understand what i did wrong yeah what's
your question yeah
okay that's yeah my question is is
do you believe
in
um
the uh
the tax you know the tax program where
they they kind of let you they just kind
of let you slide what do they call it oh
i see
it actually does occur but it occurs so
rarely
that uh in my 30 years of doing what i
do i almost never see to get approved
because the irs will only approve
waiving your taxes
if you are dead
i'm kidding you but not much i mean you
have to have zero income and zero assets
and zero potential for income you have
to prove proper status on a permanent
version of it sold my truck i've sold my
truck i don't care sold my motorcycle
you have a potential to make money
it's only 15 000. you're much better off
to go get a job or do something and get
the thing paid
is the business still open
yes yes they're not going to do an oic
this is why i called you yeah they're
not going to do an osc
somebody wants ten thousand dollars for
you to do this and they're not gonna get
it it's not gonna happen okay so you're
saying that six thousand dollars that i
spent towards this company that said
that they can get me off and compromise
you got screwed
damage yep okay yeah get online at
ramseysolutions.com and click on elp for
taxes and get with one of our real tax
people who will walk you through what
has to happen for an oic it's dead gum
near impossible to get one through i
mean i've seen like six of them in my
whole life get through and everybody
tries it and they all charge six to ten
grand each to do it
it just doesn't work i'm sorry that puts
this hour of the day around the ramsey
show in the books we'll be back with you
before you know it in the meantime
remember there's ultimately only one way
to financial peace and that's to walk
daily with the prince of peace
christchurch listener survey we want to
know what you think about the show
you'll be entered to win a 100 amazon
gift card no purchase necessary take the
survey at ramseysolutions.com
survey or text survey to 33 789
[Music]
you